من المحتمل أن تكون القدرة على إلغاء قفل جهاز iPhone الخاص بك باستخدام
معرف الوجه إحدى الميزات الأكثر
ملاءمة التي تقدمها Apple ،
ولكن منذ بداية الوباء
وبدأ الناس في ارتداء الأقنعة ،
يعقد الأمر العملية ،
لكن Apple تقول إن تحديثها الأخير
سيسمح  يبدو أن المستخدمين لاستخدام معرف الوجه دون نزع
القناع أبدًا رائعًا من
الناحية النظرية ، لكن دعونا نجربها
[موسيقى] ،
فلنبدأ فقط بقناع k95 أسود أساسي للغاية
بدون حيل ولا توجد أنماط لا شيء
مميز هنا في
الواقع لم ينجح
جربه  مرة أخرى
بالنسبة للقناع الأسود ، إنه لا
يقرأه هنا حقًا ، إنه يطلب
مني إدخال رمز المرور الخاص بي ،
حسنًا ، لنجربه مرة أخرى بشكل
سلس ، لنرى ما إذا كان بإمكاننا
خداع معرف الوجه باستخدام
قناع وجه القطة السخيف للغاية هنا
بالنظر مباشرة إلى الكاميرا بسهولة
في ثانية واحدة ،
يا إلهي ، هذه غريبة
جدًا حتى الآن ، لقد جربنا مجموعة من
الأقنعة المختلفة بما في ذلك سانتا كلوز كيفن من
المنزل بمفرده ، وبعض الأنماط
حتى مع
اللحية وكانت تعمل باستمرار
لقد جربتها عدة مرات
وحصلت عليها بالفعل للعمل مع
النظارات الشمسية في بعض الأحيان لا تعمل ، لذلك
دعونا نرى ما يحدث الآن
لم ينجح في
ذلك الوقت وقد نجح مرة أخرى
غير متسق إلى حد
ما حسنًا ، لقد نجح بالتأكيد  مرة أخرى ، أنا مندهش جدًا ،
حسنًا ، حسنًا ، لم يعمل ذلك الوقت ، لذا فنحن واحدًا
لواحد هنا ،
نحن هنا في إحدى غرف التحرير في cnn
ونحن هنا عن قصد لاختبار لمعرفة
ما إذا كانت الميزة الجديدة تعمل في الإضاءة المنخفضة
لذلك دعونا
نجربها ، نعم ، لطيفة وسهلة ،
لم تنجح في ذلك الوقت ، كنت أحاول
مرة أخرى ،
حسنًا ، لذا بعد اختبارها في عدد قليل من
الأماكن المختلفة خارج المكتب
وحالات التأجير المنخفضة بشكل عام ،
أود أن أقول إنها كانت جميلة  نتيجة غير
متسقة أو خطأ ، كان هذا مجرد إصدار تجريبي ،
لذا فمن المحتمل جدًا أن تقوم
Apple بإدخال تغييرات جديدة على التحديث
قبل إطلاقه رسميًا
[موسيقى]